i was thinking about it today i think
you came on our show you were so
young i think it was and i was asking
someone today and they looked it up and
they said they think you came on my show
on your 21st birthday
yeah is that right yeah and i don't know
one of the first shows i've ever done
yeah you're the kindest nicest person to
me ever to this day of all the talk
shows that i was ever privileged to do
your hands down my favorite well that
we have a picture we
it's really it's really hard to be mean
to you to be honest with you but
but really tell us about the ones that
were shitty
that's what i'm here for but we have a
we have a picture here of you on the
first time
and it's like your 21st birthday oh my
god how crazy is that yeah
and it's oh you're sweet but you know
you know what's amazing about you uh and
and we we've talked about this before
and either people
it's rare most people sort of put on a
persona when they come on a little bit
you're always you you're you if i run
into you on the beach you're you
wherever i see you you're you you're you
right here and you've always been kind
of you're just naturally
funny and fun to talk to were you
nervous when you first started going on
top shows because you never seemed it
no i couldn't believe that i was allowed
to right like i didn't look at it as a
job or a chore like i
genuinely look at this as like i just
have to make sure i don't curse that's
the only thing
that's the only difference you can curse
here if you want we're on uh basic
cables
i'm trying really i think this is the
only thing that i know that i
shouldn't do um otherwise i look at this
as just like a genuine opportunity to
like get to know other people
and like i grew up watching late night
like this is what i grew up on so for me
to be a part of it the first time i was
like
this is the coolest thing ever why would
i be nervous like i might never do this
again like i never thought
right that like i would see you like a
couple years later you know what i mean
like it wasn't something
how long has it been now almost 20 years
but like it's not something that i
thought would continue